[Music]
look who's here my co-host edgar
for a special episode
[Music]
she said yes oh my god
that's impossible
so someone proposed last week
in the y the most steamship
oh he's got the tambo merch wait i know
oh that's the g fuel guy oh my god
i'm so stupid it's lizard lava
oh sorry for dogging on your bathroom
selfie
that's amazing i'm so happy now yeah
legend oh he's going in the history
books
i'm really happy for you man
congratulations oh we're starting off on
a wholesome note today
yeah oh okay cool yeah there we go
[Music]
that's a reddit moment right there yo
blizzard i want to talk to you we call
in for next
y what do you say i don't even care if
people think that's crazy that's
wholesome as hell
all right sure why not confronting the
dick at your school with a text
confronting the dick at your school in a
call confronting the deck at your school
in person
confronting the dick at your school
through the white cause you know he
watches
pewdiepie screw you edward [ __ ] you
edward
sucka that's big brain i like how this
show has just become
a way for people to communicate with
each other we got proposals
we got insults
amazing
[Laughter]
i know where this is
yes
but it's so much better wake
[Music]
i don't think she likes it yeah so i've
used the actual kokobili intro
[ __ ] mad lion hilarious [ __ ]
sand
i don't like sand i will kill your child
so hard dude
i'm beginning to see a pattern here that
i'm not so sure if i like
dude we're playing hardcore no
wish-washy
uh if you're sad or a child you better
watch out
nice who am i then oh [ __ ] what the
oh my god that is not a coincidence that
is definitely not
amazing
[Laughter]
you're not having fun edgar huh you're
not enjoying this
smash like and subscribe for more epic
content edgar says it
position for kids to play flash games
one last time before they're all
gone to dusk oh yeah that's right oh
dude i love that one what is that one
called with that slade
everyone in school play that i would
love to play that again
freshman that's so cool dude we got
so many amazing submissions and we also
have
in the game the tambourine man does it
look good it does not stick out like an
eyesore
download tuber simulator the best game
amazing
damn cyber pierce 2069
okay all right the real question is what
peepee size though come on
that's actually sick upload that [ __ ]
well done club bomber
god damn it's a shame that the game is
not very good there was so much hate for
cyberpunk before it came out i
i wanted to give it a fair shot and the
more i play the more it's
so slow dude maybe picks up i don't know
i
i still want to play more but god damn
what a letdown
sven hey do you know when master pierce
will come back
he isn't coming back he started a new
minecraft series with his bed
[Music]
oh yeah i would pick
any day over you edgar you hear me this
means the world to me
you understand you're nothing it goes
then sven then you
oh he looks actually sad i'm sorry
don't worry he always looks sad it's
normal
oh you're just sleepy yeah
oh so tiny oh yeah
look at his ears look he can fly like
what my name is john i had to get a
surgery a year ago
he had chiari malformation i conditioned
where my brain is too big
i don't know if this is funny or not can
i laugh
some true big brain thank you for the
content through my recovery
oh man i'm glad you recovered well
actual big brain
we found it i didn't know that was a
thing i hope you're doing all right man
how to make a home find a penis uh-huh
place a cat oh right click
uh with shears oh i missed the shears
part
well i got bad news for who
did it better i mean he's a handsome
[ __ ] but on this photo
i actually think i take the cake it's
too much love in my face man
whoa oh my god egg it's you wait what is
this a game
third attempt to get in my oh [ __ ] i
haven't seen that
oh hell yeah whoa it comes back
whoa that's sick
[Laughter]
kill it please hell yeah
dude i want to play that is there a
download
look them up hell yeah
it's still under development but you
want to make it fun dude i'll be playing
it for sure
hell yeah they don't know that i have 10
furnaces
people just don't realize you could be
talking to a stranger but really
you never know if they have 10 furnaces
or not something to think about
where the [ __ ] are all my intros i
clearly have no control over this
last week i asked you leave your entries
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice so that's how i didn't remember
that that was
my first time reacting to the intro
amazing pewdiepie in the end of hardcore
i don't know if you guys know this but
you can actually have a attack of titan
wall of furnaces
uh episode one find salmon especially
for a crash bed for the first time
it's evolving just backwards yeah
everyone keeps thinking i
fake me being stupid really
you haven't figured out i'm dumb yet i
appreciate that at least
oh
momka says thanks for life advice pewds
uh
mumka you look cute and fluffy but i
don't trust you
oh i'll be using this thank you all
right
dude everyone loves the this one
so much it's so sick though i get it
it's nuts you guys are so talented
thank you matthew you made a miniature
version of giant meatball
well done you guys are so talented when
your meme didn't make it to hawaii
but you could see it from the mirror
stop
stop it no i don't care about bees i
don't give a [ __ ] about their feelings
i'm going to cover this whole area with
glass so can it
[ __ ] you're right [ __ ] bees sorry
at this point i only like so edgar feels
bad right edgar
he slipped into a coma because he's so
out of sadness
look at this he's completely knocked
down nothing can wake him up trust me
oh i unleash the spell you're free
hey at least someone likes my flute
place how about that again
[Music]
oh you don't like him unbelievable felix
shelby donates to various charities
every month donate small streamers on
twitch
also donate 145 000 on jack stream
pewdiepie ruthlessly murders friendly
mobs kills baby villagers
and loser village and then calls him
poor
just cares about his horse and nothing
else
yes it's about right maybe the media was
right after all
uh fears don't marry at 19 that's too
young to make decision every pewdiepie
fan realizing they'll die single
this is so sad hey i'm not going to stop
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want
no you can actually craft wool no
no i mean i knew that because i'm
minecraft veteran i know that already
no no i can't look at days
stop it
okay i like bees now they're cute
they're hella cute way cute
oh sorry sorry i thought you were
sleeping in every episode of hardcore
minecraft so far
yep yep oh my god they're so poor who
made you this poor billy just have to
watch people steal their stuff
steal their bed and finally call the
poor yeah but they're poor that's not my
fault
me not getting into the why adam warlock
707 getting too late
can someone stop this man why don't you
play with the neighbor's kid
the neighbor's kid i demand some goddamn
respect i'm a veteran
tuber simulator septic tank that's sick
i love it
we'll add it as well this one's so good
i love this one so if you didn't know
last last week i said
anyone's creation that i like will add
to tuber simulator
the most esteemed game of all time oh
that actually looks good what the [ __ ]
oh hell yeah i just started learning
italian
impressive you know you know it's coming
you know it's coming this is the stuff
that might just send me
why i think what's that do it i tell you
ksi they just say neglible
you can't say negligible that's so crazy
dude
oh negligible negligible
net
it's like walking near a cliff you have
that feeling maybe i should
maybe i should do it maybe i should jump
that's what's saying negligible is
is like keep your distance
please six feet please maintain four and
a half large piece
maya take my dad she's probably busy
making pasta yeah
scrub the young lanes
oh here we go oh i love my wife
i'm making
oh no what have i done
she makes the best pasta i'm sorry oh no
[Music]
oh god it's that way i gotta end this
episode guys uh
oh so you're human name every picture
with traffic lights
yeah god i can hate these
[Music]
[Applause]
i was in calms i was with aoc
oh don't you dare marinate me
oh my god
what this is so strange
i'm so confused you to rewind the
musical
oh god [ __ ] that makes sense
okay yeah that's kind of cool choose
your character
the neighbor's kid people skin or
jacksepticeye skin
since felix shepherd plays the flute and
pewdiepie plays a tambourine it'd be so
cool oh my god i would love
oh my god pewdiepie you want to hold his
meme review that'd be sick
just just wow just wow
[Laughter]
yeah it looks sad all the time tell them
that you're not sad
tell them huh tell them how happy you
were
why are you so sleepy dude he's fine
okay
not a little wi-fi 19 year old is too
young you can't make
life choices at that age meanwhile 20
year old felix
moving to italy to meet a girl he met
online
next man yes yes all right we're
definitely adding these
all right you know what i'm sick of this
stop flaking on the neighbors kid all
right who do you want to play with
yeah yeah yeah some boring ass [ __ ] i
don't think so
the neighbors kids are great and they
make your life happier you're welcome
where's the desk hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah
that's right you can't tap on the
keyboard i don't know if i mentioned
this in the video
all right that's it for lawyer edgar say
bye
thanks for all the submissions check out
tuber simulator now to download
the epic tambourine it'll be available
for a limited time
only and then i think next week we'll
add the stuff that you guys
did become immortalized check out the
pewdiepie submission subreddit the
most reddit reddit of all time we're
trying to make the most reddit since
we're not biggest on youtube anymore
can we at least be biggest already
please and then have a
have a great day man just have fun
remember to have fun
you never get the day back look at what
it's time for everyone's favorite part
of the video
sponsor time i know you're sitting like
this right now
nordvpn the greatest vpn of all time
nerdvpn helps you interact with the
internet safely
and epically need i say anything else
i will i use nordvpn it's a great
service
it's fast it's easy and you feel
protected
right now they have an amazing offer
where you get get this
68 off your two-year plan of nordvpn
but you also get now four months for
free
this offer is available for limited time
only so now is a great time to order
nordvpn they also have a 30 day money
back guarantee
so you can try it out if you don't like
it
which you want just 30 day money back
so take control of your internet
experience today with nordvpn
completely risk free and four months for
free right now
use the link in the description and the
code pewdiepie and start browsing safely
today now back to video